when you're getting shot in a movie
there's something called a squib that
they put on you that like explodes
and they put one right next to my
[Music]
unfortunately he died a very painful
violent death his own girlfriend jill
first shot him in the nuts as it goes
and then head shot just out a one-two
punch
funny enough nev campbell who you know
and who has been in all discreet movies
when you're getting shot in a movie
there's something called a squib that
they put on you that like
explodes and they put one right next to
my
and neb comes up to me before the shot
and it's like yo nico
i've done this is my fourth one of these
movies and i would never do
what you are about to do so we got that
going it was like well prepared going
into that scene
i feel like he would probably team up
with dewey
a solid little partnership and seek
revenge and try to protect his own
talent i think that like
dewey trevor duo would be would be
solid
i'm going to think a little outside the
box here and i would just say the cast
the people specifically hayden
panettiere and emma roberts like and
and rory we all got really close on that
movie spent
a lot of time together i'm sure you are
well aware
you know casts have to get really close
really quickly that's how
we tell good stories